je me souviens des moments agréables n'y
a pas une moment agréable vous nous
avait coûté un nouveau partenaire de
premier le choix est à nouveau centre de
vol spatial envolé tout ça parce que
notre gars cool hausse monsieur gueule
d'amour l'après yann gilg reste [__]
la mission vous allez vous traîner ça
comme une plaine brouette de casseroles
je vais pas laisser un petit pétage de
câble me détruire une seconde chance
qu'il rêve pas d'une seconde chance ton
ex patron votre prendre c'est un wine
autre ancien terrain de jeu alors à kiel
tu restes tu reprends la partie il faut
que je te présente pour l'officier de
liaison
c'est un rouleau compresseur un double
expresso jean le cam à des jeux vraiment
leygnac aujourd'hui non un triple la
petite amie de jadis pause souvenirs qui
sait même plus pourquoi on s'est séparés
parce que tu es accroc boulot et tu te
crées du boulot pour éviter le vrai vous
dise tu veux tout savoir je travaille là
dessus
tu a tout foutu en l'air et j'ai
reconstruit ma vie malgré toi
je serai un atout précieux pour notre
mission j'ai toujours été à luz
solitaire c'est comme ça j'ai pigé vous
êtes cynique voulais me sonder la
cervelle c'est pas de chance et
l'insondable
avant tout s'écroule y avait quelque
chose de grand chef garçons et filles tu
l on bosse ensemble pourquoi tu sais pas
ce qui te plaît toi tu fais ce qu'il te
plaît où il va bien j'en sais rien
goulding communiquent par ta vie ne dit
rien il a dit un tas de choses en fait
qu'est ce qu'il a dit mais un peu ma
virilité j'ai fait de la muscu je suis
un petit peu trop beau pour te voir
comme une menace allez bonne soirée
il a dit tout ça à moulins à paroles ce
type je crois que tu n'es pas revenu ici
sans raison mettons tout sur le tapis
avant que j'explose ce soir mon
commandant je me suis amusé quel que
soit l'une des multiples tranquille
prend j'ai toujours remarqué que rien ou
faux l'amusement ton existence va
devenir très très compliqué
l'avenir n'est pas seulement ce qui va
arriver
c'est une force brutale
doté d'un solide sens de l'humour et les
kivu la minera si vous ne faites pas
attention